The conclusion of "Black Adam"
leaves its characters in very
interesting places for future DCEU movies.
But what about Pierce Brosnan's Dr. Fate?
The following contains spoilers for "Black Adam."
Besides Dwayne Johnson's soundstage-shaking frame
filling most of the scenes of "Black Adam," the
hierarchy of power in the DC universe hasn't
so much as changed as it has spread out with
the addition of the Justice Society of America.
Besides marking the first big-screen iteration of
Black Adam, the film also marks the arrival of the
classic superteam. This iteration features Carter
Hall, aka Hawkman, Cyclone, Atom Smasher, and
the stoic, Doctor Fate played by Pierce Brosnan.
In "Black Adam," it's established early
on that both Carter and the good Doctor,
also known as Kent Nelson, go way back. The wise
old mystic is much older than he appears, living
a life riddled with harrowing visions of bleak
futures that he's thankfully managed to avoid.
"My vision has shown me the future."
However, the reawakening of an ancient force
paves the way for a fate that not everyone
will be able to outrun, leading Nelson
to take drastic steps to avoid it. Now,
with the dust settled, what's
Doctor Fate's prognosis,
and what does it mean for the future of
the DCEU on the verge of making a comeback?
If you've got this far, you've no doubt checked
"Black Adam" off your watchlist and seen that
Brosnan's charming master of magic sacrificed
himself to get Black Adam back in the fight.
It's a bit of a shame the former Bond's
involvement in the franchise was so brief
after being considered a highlight following the
film's release. All that's left now is an empty
chair on Carter Hall's decked-out Cruiser and a
helmet without an owner. Well, for now, at least.
In the comics, the Helmet of Fate
has had many owners over the years,
with Nelson being one of its most notable.
Even those not explicitly chosen to don the
helm have tried on the headgear, including
dry-witted Hellblazer John Constantine and
even Superman himself. On some occasions,
however, the helm has been a perfect fit for
other heroes donning the mantle of Doctor
Fate. Nelson's own bloodline has stepped
up to take over, and there have even been
total newcomers to the game of good, evil,
and hand-wavey magic spells. However, among those
contributing to Fate's legacy is a contender that,
given a little bit of tweaking here and there,
could be located not far from Adam's home turf.
Currently, in the comics, the doctor on
duty isn't Kent Nelson but his nephew,
Khalid Nassour. Debuting in 2015, Khalid is an
Egyptian-American who has been linked to many of
DC's superteams beyond just the Justice Society.
Currently, he's a member of Justice League Dark,
a united force against the demonic and hellish
threats to humanity and led by none other than
John Constantine. Considering the character
is set to return to the big screen with Keanu
Reeves reprising the role, it feels almost like
fate that the next in line for that shiny gold
helmet is part of a team that Warner Bros. has
been wanting to bring to live-action for years.
With Constantine coming back to exorcise some
demons and a helmet without a hero to don it,
"Black Adam" feels like a great stepping-off
point to establish another new area of the DC
universe that is fighting to make a comeback.
Also, given Khalid's Egyptian heritage,
it'd be cool if his origin story could be
altered and he somehow winds up in Kahndaq
to meet Black Adam just like his uncle did.
Who knows? The hierarchy of power in the DC
universe might be changing after all, and
it could become the perfect prescription.